有一个病人
他吃了麻油鸡
和一些补品之后
睡觉的时候发现
哎呀手臂上怎么
一块一块一块红的出来了
然后哎呦又痒又痒
痒的简直刺刺的
哎原来这个
就是荨麻疹发作了
哇那要怎么办
我教你啊
先OO
然后再来
按1穴位
搔痒马上先缓解很多
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
这一集要跟你分享
荨麻疹
湿疹
异位性皮肤炎
皮蛇发作
怎么快速止痒
急性期
不能吃这些地雷食物
荨麻疹半夜发作
2穴位止痒
万一哪一天你就像
那个病人一样不小心
吃到不好的东西
咪呀了半夜荨麻疹
发作怎么办
荨麻疹怎么止痒
先不要抓
教你这一招
先按穴道
再敷冷毛巾
立刻舒服一半以上
来有两个穴位止痒
曲池
血海
曲池穴在哪
曲池就是把你手肘弯
弯弯 到手心向着自己的时候
在手肘这个地方的
一个横纹上面
就在这里
叫做曲池穴
按下去呢会有酸酸的
有一点点疼痛的感觉
哎按起来真的酸酸的呢
它帮助你清热解毒
帮助你把痒的感觉哎减轻了
另外一个穴位叫
血海穴
它是在膝盖内侧的上缘啊
往上大约三个指幅
你用大拇指这样按压
它盖在那个
膝盖上
然后呢大拇指所指的那一个穴
就叫做血海穴
你就用这个大拇指
在这里这样按一按按一按
你把这刚才这两个穴道
一个是曲池一个是血海
你就在这里
来按一按
能够缓解皮肤发痒的效果
是非常非常好的
而这两个穴呢
每次按压大概5秒到10秒
重复两分钟
痒的时候都可以按的
穴位按完之后
用毛巾湿敷或是冰敷5分钟
靠血管收缩和冰凉感
痒的感觉会大大的减半
急性发作期啊
记住一件事情
洗澡别用太烫的水了
根据统计台湾有500万人
曾经得过一次荨麻疹
换句话说平均
每5个人就有一个中标
你说多还不多啊
是啊最近我身边的人也中标呢
荨麻疹有两种
第一种是急性荨麻疹
不到几周就可以痊愈
大多数都是食物过敏所引起的
第二种叫慢性的荨麻疹
它反覆发作啊
超过6周以上
诱发的原因很复杂了
而且女性患者
比男性患者还要多出两倍
如果你发现
自己超过6周还没改善
千万别在那里撑着了
赶快让医生
帮你找出原因
推荐你找中医师看
效果很好哦
换季是荨麻疹高峰
急性荨别吃7种食物
荨麻疹最爱在春秋
换季的时候出没
会和寒热湿
一起来跟你作怪
当气温忽寒忽热
湿度忽高忽低
身体防御的能力就下降了
就容易突然起红疹子
痒到抓不停
如果你冬天再大吃
姜母鸭
麻油鸡
烧烤
重口味
体内湿热一直上升
荨麻疹就很容易被诱发
健康的人
想预防荨麻疹发作
9类食物不能吃过量
羊肉牛肉鸭肉鹅肉
辣椒胡椒咖喱咖啡
还有添加物多的零食
平常你可以吃芭乐
奇异果这类富含
维生素C的新鲜蔬果
帮助抗发炎减轻痒感
冬天别吃太多的
烧烤炸辣的食物
如果你现在是
荨麻疹急性期
不要吃
海
鲜虾
螃蟹
蛤蜊
还有像
核桃
杏仁等等坚果
泡面和辛辣的刺激食物
都容易诱发荨麻疹
急性期一定要忌口
急性期可以吃什么
三个重点
原型食物
新鲜食物
少加工的食物
粉丝留言跟我分享
他以前熬夜上班
很少吃蔬果都是吃肉
吃海鲜加上睡眠不足
急性荨麻疹就发作
痒到他一直抓
还抓破皮
真的很痛苦
自从改吃原型食物
不碰麸质的
不吃精致的糖
荨麻疹就再也不复发了
看起来
如果要顾的好
我们嘴巴不可以乱吃东西
没错
调整好饮食和作息
荨麻疹就能很快的远离你
芦荟加它
治湿疹效果神奇
湿疹是皮肤炎的总称
像是异位性皮肤炎
脂漏性皮肤炎
汗疱疹
这些让皮肤产生
发炎红肿脱屑
组织液渗出的状况
都可以称之为湿疹
湿疹痒到受不了要怎么办
用芦荟帮助你立刻止痒
你知道吗
唐朝有个诗人叫做刘禹锡
他在他的传信方里头记载
他说他年轻的时候得了湿疹
怎么治都治不好
后来遇到一个卖药人
卖药的人教他
芦荟一两加炙甘草半两
磨成粉
先用温水洗一洗湿疹的地方
再敷上药粉
没想到病情很快就好转了
甚至于它的效果
是非常的
神奇
家里有种芦荟的人
可以拿来给它敷一敷
很不错
你们家有种芦荟吗
这样敷一敷
就知道有效了
芦荟是皮肤痒的大救星
有四个功效
止痒消红肿杀菌
还有修复受损的皮肤
而且更棒的是湿疹疮疡痔疮
也能用芦荟来帮助你改善它
那市面上
有卖芦荟凝胶也可以用吗
成份很天然的话
你可以试试看
但是我还是推荐
用天然芦荟最好
现在我来跟你讲
西医怎么治湿疹
很多人一碰到湿疹或皮肤问题
第一个反应就是用消炎药
抗过敏药或擦类固醇
这些药的目的就是帮你止痒
短时间效果很好
但是我告诉你
长期使用就不太好
你的皮肤会越来越薄
甚至增加
骨质疏松
高血压的风险
代价可不小
要消灭湿疹有一个大绝招
比什么都重要
就是千万不要去抓
挠痒痒就算了
你一直抓抓破皮
我告诉你就感染了
皮肤只会越来越糟
越来越坏
给你一个新观念
皮肤发炎并不是坏事
而是身体在对抗外来的刺激
湿疹是脏腑功能失衡的信号
要真正治本
中医强调的
是从根本来调理脏腑
提升你的免病的能力
而不是只靠压制发炎
1汤止异位性皮肤炎的痒
任何皮肤病都可以治
中医治皮肤病
先看体质与病因
分症状
它是属于风火湿燥寒
哪一种
再分虚跟实就这样
是急性的或是慢性的
湿疹里面最常见的皮肤病
就是异位性皮肤炎
多属于热性的
天气热或吃了
太多辛辣燥热等等
就容易发作
这种人晚上还加上难以入眠
痒得受不了
有两个方法可以改善
第1个喝绿豆汤
绿豆能够清热解毒
降火止痒
但不要喝冰的哦
否则冰品
就会把热闷在身体里头
反而容易气血运行
不利于脾胃的排湿功能
先暂时不要吃
鱼虾蟹竹笋芋头
以及辛辣刺激的食物
或燥热的补品
例如麻油鸡人参胡椒
姜葱蒜之类的
这些会加重
体内的湿热和炎症
所以多吃
绿豆苦瓜冬瓜菊花薏仁茯苓
这些清热的食材
第2个
洗澡可以用
大麦汤
不分体质都能止痒
医宗金鉴里头记载
把1公升的大麦煮成汤
先熏后洗
熏什么意思
就是那个
正在烧着有蒸气的时候
去熏一熏
你那个痒的地方
先熏等到这个汤
渐渐渐渐冷了
可以拿来洗
假如你患了这个毛病
明天不妨就来试试
这个方法
不只是对异位性皮肤炎有效
连牛皮癣或者是荨麻疹
湿疹都有效
秋冬易发皮蛇
麻油＋它
痛痒立刻救
台湾人得到带状疱疹
也就是俗称的皮蛇
又叫做飞
蛇皮 蛇或者飞蛇
跟水痘
它其实是同一种病毒
机率高达三分之一
季节交替或50岁以上
免疫力已经比较低了的
这两种人最容易诱发
带状疱疹急性期发作
不但会痒
而且会像火烧
像针扎一样的
痛得个不行
你可以这样
做到 中药店买雄黄粉
加一点麻油来调
把它调一调
调成像膏一样的
然后敷在患处
大概一两天就能够结痂
可以帮助舒缓
那个痛那个痒
但是要注意
如果症状严重
一定要赶快去看医生
尤其是年长的
或免疫力低下的朋友
要及早治疗
饮食上急性期
也要避免发物
鸭肉鹅肉牛肉猪头皮
这些都是不能吃的
皮蛇秋冬是不是容易发作
对为什么呢
你知道吗
因为免疫系统在这个时候
特别容易下降
就是因为你所有的能量
都拿去对抗冷去了
于是潜伏在脊髓神经的
这个水痘的病毒
就可能在这个时候
被引发出来了
沿着神经的纤维
在神经的末梢这个地方
开始滋生
这个时候就出现水泡
就产生剧烈的疼痛和痒
另外再告诉你一个小知识
如果小朋友
在小的时候得到过水痘
反而他能够终身
都不再得这个皮蛇
当然他要是说
没有发透的话仍然会
但是在小的时候
要是发透
这个皮蛇就不容易再发生
所以你家有小小孩的话
还有这个机会喔
亲爱的粉丝们
我们已经开启会员频道了
如果你认同胡医师推广中医
照顾自己健康的理念
欢迎每月小额支持
只要花两杯咖啡的钱
或成为VIP赞助者
有你同行
我们才能走得更远
真心感谢你